[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today derekson
Dallas hi Derek what's up yes sir so my
wife has a question um where is she
we've taken she's at work right now okay
she we we took FPU we've got everything
listed out from smallest to largest
we've knocked out some debt already with
with the bonus that I got she gets a
10year bonus in
January uh she got seven school loans
here about 19,000 worth and her her
question is for peace of
mind the the credit cards are a lower
balance so theoretically going by the
program we'd have to hit the school
loans but if if we I'm sorry you said
the credit cards are a lower balance you
me the school loans are lower
balance no the school loans are are
larger balances but but lower monthly
payments and if if we did it Accord
according to FPU we we do the school
loans before the credit cards but we did
the credit credit card whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa you must have flunked you said
you just told me the the balances on the
credit cards are
smaller uh yes okay you're supposed to
pay off smallest to largest not payment
balance there is there's two school
loans that are larger than or smaller
than the the credit card okay okay so
what there the question is if we pay off
the the larger balance on the credit
card to get up to free up a larger
monthly payment to go towards other
things versus if I pay off two credit
cards it frees up
about7 can I be smart for a second go
ahead go ahead if you had a plan it got
you where you
are why would you question this why
don't you just do it we've taught 10
million people how to do
this but why are you trying to be a
genius now I'm not she's just wanting
the the snowball to be bigger she's
wanting the snowball to be working her
way it doesn't work her
way I gotcha pay off the smallest to the
largest I gotcha all kinds of Studies
have backed up that what we're doing
actually
works including 10 million people have
going through Financial Peace University
and getting out of debt yes sir yes sir
I agree okay I'll get past the smart
like and I'll calm down a second now
let's try a second let's go back at it
for a second so the do you need to be do
we need to walk through reinforcement on
why we teach that did you not you all
didn't grasp that from Financial Peace
University no we we understood it it was
just a question that she wanted more
reassurance she she's a government
official so she was was out a lot of the
classes and I was the one that was
attending so uh just because required
meetings that she had to attend so so
she like missed the class yeah he does
need reinforcement Dave Derek it's okay
to admit it you need the reinforcement
to be able to answer the question no no
no no no she needs to go through that
lesson well that's true that's the
answer that's true because she wants a
logical understanding and because she
doesn't have this knowledge base that
you've got that's okay that makes more
sense than I went to class and I
disagree while I'm broke yeah no we we
don't disagree it was just no not we
her okay cuz she was the one asking the
question she's not here but but she now
I can defend her because she has an
honest question about something cuz she
doesn't know she didn't go to that she
didn't go to that lesson right correct
okay cool that's fine I completely I
completely understand that so let's go
back then and uh instead of picking on
her um because she's not here that's not
fair but
um we can do one or two things all right
let's do number one uh when did you take
the
class uh it was started a few months ago
we just finished it up like three weeks
ago before right after Thanksgiving at
your church or online at church yes did
you get the online application as a part
of the package that you guys got into
yes sir do you have access to the lesson
to watch it uh yes sir okay pull up the
lesson on debt and the two of you sit
there and watch it and don't you say a
word let her let her catch up with the
knowledge base okay because here now
that that that'll help now but then
here's what for for your benefit at this
moment and the rest of the people
listening here here's what she's going
to hear for the first time and that is
this I personally when I started this as
a a math nerd wanted to pay off the
highest interest rate first which is
mathematically correct it's only
mathematically correct if you have the
same probability of
completion however when you pay off the
highest interest rate first or you start
monking around with paying off balances
that feel good you don't have the same
probability of completing the whole get
out of debt plan and when you enter
probability into the mathematics because
you messed with the behavior tool then
you you you you lower your complete rate
and all that Garg to say if you don't go
get out of debt because you screw with
the plan then your plan was dumb you
know that's what it amounts to so what
what we've proven is is that personal
finances 80% Behavior it's only 20% head
knowledge it's not a math problem if we
were doing math we wouldn't have gotten
in credit card D it's not a math problem
it's a behavior problem so the way you
attack a behavior problem is with a
behavior based solution not a math-based
solution that's what we started doing 30
years ago and it's been highly
successful that's why I was leaning back
in and being a smart elic Okay uh but I
didn't understand at the moment that I
did that that your wife hadn't even seen
the lesson so bad on me so uh anyway now
so the way we what we know is is that if
you go to the gym and you work out and
you eat salads for a week and you gain 4
lbs you will quit
even if it would work a month from now
you won't keep doing it so your
probability of completion is zero you
have human beings have to have a sense
of traction we have to have some
solutions we have to have a sense of
progress a feedback loop psychologists
call it and we need a feedback loop that
says you're winning if I go to the gym
and I lose weight I'll keep going to gym
if I quit eating Big Max and I lose
weight I'll quit eating Big Max you will
keep in the loop if you pay off some
debt you'll pay off some debt you'll pay
off some debt you'll stay in the food
back Loop that's why the debt snowball
works and that's why it's been more
successful than any other get out of
debt plan in America create your free
every dooll budget today the simplest
way to budget for your life